[Applause]
[Music]
bts knows how to close out a show the
k-pop group took the stage at the 2021
amas to perform their hit and ama
winning song butter
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the singers brought their music video to
life delivering a perfectly
choreographed dance routine i mean like
we're just here to have a good time with
the armies
now bts was not expected to perform
butter alone the k-pop stars were
originally set to hit the stage with
megany stallion to perform this remix of
the hit track
so smooth like the car i ride even your
best party planner couldn't catch this
vibe big mouse and i make a hater stay
on a job and i'll be on these girls next
like the back of their box but the
rapper dropped out due to an unexpected
personal matter on saturday which she
shared on twitter i did what i had to do
but that didn't stop bts from pulling
off their two epic performances their
first of the night was literally out of
this world
[Applause]
[Music]
that's the k-pop super group joining
coldplay to perform their song my
universe for the first time together on
stage hi guys
before the show they couldn't help but
share their excitement over performing
for their fans the army in person again
we waited this for
so
so long time so it's like a dream yeah
it's like a dream i mean we actually
dreamed of this dream so it's crazy and
it ended up being a big night for
bts the band took home three amas artist
of the year best pop song and favorite
pop duo or group during their acceptance
speech they sent all the love to their
fans nobody
could have ever bet
on the odds of us standing here
receiving this award
except
exceptional army exceptional
you